the world is so big and you are but a
tiny human and yet you're going to go
out to kill with nothing but a single
arrow and the ability to call your
weapon back to you in Titan Souls
movement is simple just a role in Run
button and a small cooldown you explore
a peculiar world of old ruins and clear
waters looking for a fight but in this
game the only fights you get our boss
battles the demo offers a small glimpse
of what you'll be getting with the full
release an area filled with boss fights
waiting for your arrow but each of them
takes skill and timing to defeat and all
they need is one hand and your tiny life
you'll die a lot but each time you die
you learn a bit more learning their weak
spot and aiming true can finish them off
and there's no better feeling than a
well-timed air
it all ends in a shadow of colossus
inspired cutscene where you collect
their soul and bam you're just there no
new moves no special treatment just
start wandering for your next fight
whether you choose q by fisty cuffs or I
sprain you're in for a real treat and
this demo is something I would
definitely recommend with serene
environments laid-back soundtrack and
three beastly boss fights this Titan
Souls demo is super promising and super
free you can check it out now before the
games full release on April 14th and see
if this tiny Colossus game is up your
alley